War as horrible as it is often gives
opportunities to certain groups so
African-Americans former slaves are able
to prove themselves as Citizens Jews did
this an enormous number in World War II
Henry Kissinger I wrote about before he
really only gets recognized as an
American he's a German Jewish immigrant
he's seen as an American because of his
service in World War II so the bright
side of this is that often in the case
of War on your own side you will let go
of some of your prejudices
Ulysses Grant has a total transformation
he goes into the Civil War and
anti-semite and a racist he comes out
with actually very enlightened views
because he sees what Jewish soldiers and
what African-American soldiers did
what's Ulysses Grant's story what uh
what do you learn from him was he a hero
or a villain of this war
I think he's a hero uh though he's a
flawed hero as all heroes are
um he's a man from Ohio and Illinois who
uh was a really a failed businessman
time and again
um and uh had an ability to command
people in War uh where did this come
from he was a clear communicator and an
empathetic figure he tended to drink too
much but he was the kind of person
people wanted to follow they trusted him
and so in battle that became very
important and the second thing is he did
his homework and he had a sense of the
terrain he had a sense of the
environment he was operating in and he
was ruthless in pursuing what he had
studied so he turns out it battles as
like Vicksburg and elsewhere to actually
undertake some pretty revolutionary
maneuvers and then he figures out that
the advantage now is on his side in
numbers and he just poundsly pounds him
to death similar what the United States
does at the end of World War II with
Germany and Japan he comes out of the
war Grant does he's a believer in Union
he wants to protect
um former slaves
and other groups and he tries to use the
military for that purpose he's limited
and then as president he tries to do
that as well uh right now uh we still
use many of the laws that were passed
during Grant's presidency to prosecute
insurrectionists so the 900 or so people
who have been prosecuted for breaking
into the capital and attacking police on
January 6. those insurrectionists
they've been prosecuted under the 1871
anti-clu Klux Klan law so that's a big
accomplishment by Grant and we still
benefit from it the problem is Grant was
not a great politician unlike Lincoln
he didn't give good speeches he wasn't a
persuasive figure in a political space
and so he had trouble building support
for what he was doing uh even though he
was trying to do what in the end I think
were the right things